I want to talk a little bit today about
one of these very invasive investigative
techniques that is happening today and
that we don't know enough about but
which is very dangerous and that is
government hacking and so when I say
government hacking what I mean is law
enforcement primarily but also
intelligence agencies basically breaking
into your phone your laptop your
computer and collecting information
about you from there and we know that a
lot of nations do this from this amazing
work by the University of Toronto
Citizen lab we know that you know Mexico
does it Ethiopia does it Egypt does it
all the best governments are doing it
and they're targeting human rights
activists and journalists and minority
communities in order to get information
our government does it too they call it
alternately things like with these
euphemistic names like lawful hacking as
if it's always lawful when isn't that
the question is it lawful or not they
also call it something like
extraordinary access as if it's really
extraordinary like it's so wonderful
or it's extraordinary as in it's out of
the ordinary
like they're not doing it all the time
and but I think the British at least
have an honest name for it which is
equipment interference which is actually
what it is so thank you to the Brits for
that but I call that government hacking
and what it does is basically our
government has we don't have any
statutes that actually enable or say
it's okay to do this what law
enforcement particularly the FBI has
been doing is they've been just getting
your basic search warrant and then
saying well that's enough we can do once
we get a search warrant we can do
whatever we want even if it's this sort
of novel and different kind of
investigative technique and the problem
with that is that you know I talked
about the warrant and how important it
is but it really is um you know sort of
inadequate
certain kinds of problems and government
hacking is different from your average
run-of-the-mill searches that often
happen with a warrant in five particular
ways first of all the amount and quality
of data that's available there is more
and more sensitive information on my
laptop than in 50 or 100 phone calls
that I might make the invasiveness of
the practice so government hacking can
use not just to access data that's
stored in my laptop but to do things
like turn on the camera on my laptop or
turn on the microphone on my smart TV
and listen to the stuff that I say
basically converting these consumer
electronics that we have into these
ubiquitous in-home surveillance devices
which is super useful and if you are
want to find out what everybody's doing
the they by the very nature of
collecting information in this way the
access to the computer can change data
that's on the computer how can somebody
who's charged following one of these
kinds of searches know that the
information that's being used against
them has integrity that it is in fact
what the information is and not
something that was either intentionally
or mistakenly altered by the search
procedure and defense attorneys aren't
able to question this because the
government says that the tech techniques
are classified or they basically rent
the techniques from these companies that
sell surveillance software or
surveillance services to governments and
they claim it's a trade secret so you
can't really inquire about it or
investigate it there then there are the
cybersecurity harms you know defense is
hard we all know about the cyber
insecurity incidents whether it's you
losing your credit card from Target or
t.j.maxx
it's the denial of service attacks that
take down websites or banks and we it's
people getting fished or and have
their password stolen or we all know
about these problems and that's because
defense is hard the attacker can attack
a million times and only has to win once
the defender has to be there and like
win every single time but with
government hacking instead of making
sure that the government is incentivized
to be on the defensive and to help
secure our networks now you have the
government as an incentivized attacker
who's interested in maintaining security
vulnerabilities so that it can do
surveillance and get into people's
computers and it's a well-funded
attacker what is that put the kind of
collective the government is supposed to
protect us from these attackers but now
the government is an attacker itself and
so are other governments so you have
this problem where for example the
government might lose the exploits and
when you lose control of the exploits
that means somebody else can use it
so this is exactly what happened with
the recent wanna cry attacks if people
heard about that it shut down hospitals
and caused like a billion dollars worth
of damage around the world that wanna
cry attack was based on an NSA exploit
that had been stolen what about the
problem of whether companies are
informed about vulnerabilities in their
products so that they can fix it the
government now has an incentive instead
of informing companies you should fix
this problem to keep the problem secret
and keep the pathway open so that the
attack can happen and the surveillance
can take place okay so they're just
causes these cyber security harms and
then finally have the problem of public
trust in order to convince people to
download malware we've seen the
government pretend to be an AP reporter
we've seen the FBI host a child
pornography service for two weeks we've
seen the FBI do spear phishing attacks
we've seen the FBI ask companies to
subvert the security on their products
and put backdoors in or write malicious
software updates
so that instead of being secured your
devices become insecure
how can people trust software updates
and the companies that we do business
with how can people trust the government
when there's this fraud going on in
order to convince people to install
malware on their machines
[Music]